so
one of the things that I feel like is
going to take me to the next level is
obviously taking some of these ass shots
out Blac Chyna giving herself a make
under as part of her so-called
life-changing Journey now I'm moving
here in life so I can grow China who's
34 says she got her first silicone
enhancements when she was just 19. 15
years later she's removing what's left
from her breasts and backside I'm gonna
go get my
butts ox
reduce and also to my breasts because
honestly I feel like
I'm like past that stage I've been here
done that this is actually my fifth time
hopefully my last time you know
she's not only changing the way she
looks but how much of her we get to see
on the Jason Lee show Chyna announced
she's getting rid of her only fans page
which has reportedly made her hundreds
of millions of dollars by people that I
had to cut off a certain business
relationships I had to kind of cut off
so I just wanted to like just really
focus on me trying to set an example for
my kids and hopefully Inspire like some
people to even try it you know because
we're around like alcohol and like it's
drugs here this this you know what I
mean and it's really easy to get like
sucked into that into that world those
kids 10 year old King Cairo her son with
Tyga and six-year-old dreamed her
daughter with Rob Kardashian I just feel
like having like a good relationship
with the other parent and co-parents and
it's like a healthy type of thing and
it's something that a lot of people need
to like practice she also wants to be
around for a long time for her babies
another reason why she's done dumping
her pumped up look because you can't get
sick you can die have complications and
all this other crazy stuff I haven't had
any crazy complications since I got it I
got it when I was 19 years old
but now I'm moving here in life so I'm
like out of my ass so I can grow she
gave fans an update after the surgery
I mean recovery mode right now got my
bandages on as you can see got my
breasts reduced one of the best
decisions I could have done in a very
long time I had to like come out show
out you know I'm doing good I'm doing
good I'm just feeling blessed right now
China's never been shy about her
personal drama last year she
unsuccessfully sued the Kardashians for
100 million dollars accusing them of
damaging her career she now admits she's
learned something from the famous family
Courtney said you ruined her whole
wedding thing because all her sisters
were in court with you and not over
there with her sitting on the dresses
because they stick together
[Music]
foreign